Amber Tamlin is an actor she's an
activist she's a poet and guess what
she's a writer too her new may I hold up
your book her new book aims to help
people follow your intuition it's called
listening in the dark women reclaiming
the power of intuition so it features
personal essays from 15 women most of
them many of them you know including Amy
Poehler Huma abedin and tamlin's own
mother Bonnie I loved her story Tamlin
edited the essays and wrote her own she
joins us first on CBS mornings to
discuss good morning to you Amber good
morning this is so great it's a very
easy read and I think it's so relatable
but one of the things you point out is
that sometimes we're taught to ignore
our intuition you're saying no do not do
that because intuition is what and does
what yeah so one of the things that I
wanted to write about with this book was
sort of the underpinning of all of these
conversations we have as women when it
comes to rage and equality all of the
different feelings that we have and the
idea of nurturing this gut feeling that
we have have and what happens when we
really think about that as a muscle as
an actual form of intelligence that we
can use as much as we use rational
thought and once I started reading all
these essays I was completely blown away
by the science behind it and how
important this is I love what Huma says
she says you can have all the academics
you can have all the rationality all the
education but sometimes it comes down to
just doing what feels right that's
exactly right that is so true yes and I
think that there is so much emphasis on
intelligence and knowledge as fact-based
rationale that we can look at but there
is this other part of us there's this
tool this vital tool that is our
physical bodies telling us things what
our gut tells us what the inside of our
voice is and what that has to say about
our lives Yeah you mentioned the word
gut yes and you write about trusting
your body the body knows first yes why
is it important to listen to our bodies
because we all get that feeling
sometimes we listen sometimes we don't
well I think especially you know men's
intuition is really fascinating to me
and really a big important part of this
conversation
of course they do I think yes
I knew you could say that exactly I mean
you do you know but I think for women
it's been much more
um suppressed and oppressed for for many
many many years and so the important
factor here is reconnecting with our
bodies and what they tell us and we're
sort of in an age when women are really
told not to listen to their bodies that
they are not the Arbiters of their own
experience or their own physical
livelihood and so to go against that and
talk about intuitive process and
intuitive intelligence is like this very
vital tool in this moment for us to be
able to think and feel and be connected
to each other and to our own physical
selves you come to the subject through
your own experience and the tragedy of
losing a mentor uh and not listening to
your body and then going back and
finding out why but then you've got all
these essays from other people with
their experiences how did you go about
including this not including that how do
you edit somebody else's intuition oh
it's such a it's such a great question I
loved editing this I think for me it was
really important to have do different
people women from across Industries
doctors artists activists writers who
were who didn't necessarily know what
the answer was right because it's really
hard for us to describe what that
feeling is of intuition and and our gut
to really give it a definitive
definition and so I wanted women to say
you know like lakuma when I approached
her and she was like I would love to do
this I have no idea what I'm going to
write about and I don't even know if I
have a connection to my intuition I said
great let's write about that that's
perfect because this is not a book that
gives answers necessarily it's helping
you to strengthen the muscle of how to
ask questions and intuition can work to
tell you to do something yes also work
to tell you not to do something that's
right but how do you know Amber when
it's intuition and maybe I'm just afraid
or maybe I'm just anxious well there's
all have those feelings too absolutely
and I think one of the biggest issues
that women face is second guessing
themselves and confusing intuition for
anxiety which is something that we feel
feel often but I think again there's a
great conversation with America Ferreira
that she and I have in this it's like a
conversation between friends she's one
of the most brilliant women I know and
she talks a lot about this as a muscle
to be strengthened so the more that you
lean on it the more you use it however
scary it is however you know unsure you
are it gets stronger and so your ability
to trust yourself and to hear yourself
strengthens over time and Gail men do
have intuition I was reading this book
and I didn't I was speaking to me and
then you guys didn't have it I was just
posing the question he was speaking to
me and I'd come to a line that would
mention women I'd be like oh yeah that's
right it's supposed to be for you but
it's for everybody but can I just say
that I hope our young boys and I hope
Men read this book for real because I
think it's so important for us to see
intuitive intelligence and trusting our
gut through a feminine lens as well it's
such an important part of who we are as
a collective human race yeah no you have
a book one a person who deals with
animals and says animals always go with
their they have an instinct that's right
they don't second-guess they're not
making t-shirts Ember it's really good
thank you so much for coming this
morning the name of Amber's book is
listening in the dark it's on sale now
it's on sale now wherever you like to
buy your books we'll be right back